[Music]
this word authentic we really have seen
a lot of in the last couple of years I
would say particularly particularly in
this area of so-called gender identity
in the notion of having an authentic
self I find it I find it quite troubling
that there seems to be a shift away from
what we understand as sociologists as
the self that obviously we will all have
a some of the kind of sense of ourselves
that is in relationship to the social
world to the political world the
economic world that we inhabit so this
idea of authenticity is often I think
used very ideologically in these kinds
of discussions or in terms of the claims
of young people invested in cosmetic
surgery to suggest that there's some
kind of inner self that is pre-social
that is not affected by the kind of
messages that we have from the media
remember that obviously the media is
extremely powerful and it's in the hands
of you know very few very powerful
corporations and all of the economic
interests that are that are at stake in
terms of a hugely profitable cosmetic
surgery industry that we know it can be
quite hard to to find accurate estimates
of the of the global worth of you know
different industries I've seen estimates
ranging from 11 billion right up to 43
billion US dollars in but what we do
know is that cosmetic surgery is a
hugely booming business both in terms of
the surgical procedures and the very
common increasingly prevalent invasive
procedures so I want to start by raising
your question there's a a woman whose
story I was reading recently I won't say
her name out of respect but I'll just
call her Jane Smith Jane Smith was a
survivor of the pypy breast implant
scandal that some of you will probably
remember from the best part of ten years
ago now 2012 is when that scandal broke
if you remember with the pap scandal
women had breast implants put into their
bodies that had industrial grade
silicone and were far were twice as
likely to rupture than other implants so
there were forty eight thousand women in
this country alone
that were victims of this scandal they
waited five years for any kind of
financial compensation they got three
thousand pounds which would not even
cover the cost of the original the
original operation and Jane Smith as
just one example of these women has had
to have five further operations to try
and correct some of the the impact of
having this toxic substance leaked into
her body so we can raise the question
we've got all these sort of ideological
words like authentic or confidence or
you know boosting self-esteem we go I
would like to raise the question is Jane
Smith a more authentic person now with
this toxic material in her body that can
never be fully got rid of that as that
has affected her ability to work her
ability to raise children her ability to
function in the world not to mention all
the psychological impacts as well as the
physical impacts and I think we really
have to look at get away from some of
the euphemistic language that tends to
be used in these discussions and start
to think about whose interest is this
serving who's making huge profits out of
this what are the implications in terms
of sexual politics because we know that
it is overwhelmingly men who are
carrying out these procedures and women
90 in this country 90% of all cosmetic
surgery is carried out on women's bodies
so those are the kinds of questions I
think we should be looking at and then
really questioning what do we mean by
this notion of authenticity for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts in ideas
her III TV
you